some of the stories are just amazing
that you talk about is all things some
guys talked about stuff that happened in
Vietnam there was some UFO incidences
there that happened on a couple of the
rivers I mean and it just goes on and on
and on you're like well listen not
everybody can be lying about this no and
most people I mean with some of the
strange things that I've seen I didn't
go running out let me tell everybody
about it you know we haven't happy
having this conversation now me sharing
there's one with the red lights
the funny part was the night that I saw
those lights Donna was gone from the
house my neighbor was gone the kids were
all gone I couldn't share with anybody I
want to show somebody you know but like
I couldn't my phone wouldn't pick up the
red light so I couldn't even videotape
it to show anybody but so you're like
well what kind of how do you validate
that right yeah Mike said he was saying
stuff against awesome red lights in the
sky oh what's he taking yeah Mike smoke
and I need some of this so you know you
kind of keep them to yourself but at
some point as this thing becomes more
and more relevant someone can let the
cat out of the bag yeah and they're
gonna come out and say hey man these
things exist we're not the only ones
here you know unfortunately religion
isn't set up like you thought it is and
I think people who are afraid well if
it's not set up like that why should I
be a good guy that I'm Scott here and
rob and kill right I'm just gonna be
wait all the dots are gonna be connected
and listen you either a good person or
you're not you know you either [ __ ]
yeah and do the right thing because it
is the right thing to do or you're one
of those guys it just isn't
I mean if you know if you're obviously
hurting animals I know that a bullet
will draw that real problem real quick
kind of that guy that's gonna hurt
animals I know what I'm saying so we're
at a place right now with mankind where
I think about every 50 years there's a
significant change in the way we think
about things you talk to people today
about certain events that have taken
place I think we've all seen something
that is kind of odd or out of place
that's would be considered paranormal
but who do you tell you know and there's
so much of this are you really looking
for attention Mike yeah that's how
you're trying to get all the attention
maybe your parents didn't love you very
much
hahaha but listen at the end of the day
something is going on and when we see
the stuff that Danny's picked up on his
we seen on TV shows it's the same exact
whatever it is that we're looking at
there there's something going on yeah
and how they're all interrelated
and how they correspond with each other
is still yet to be seen but I think that
through some great podcasts and some
information telling and the stuff that
Rogen's doing and you're doing you start
to connect the dots and I think Beth you
know Damian I put this figure it out
dude right now I think we've covered I
just really want to find out more about
the Brazilians yeah that's the icing on
the cake that is hopefully this doesn't
give like buried on the internet and
forgotten I mean hopefully something you
know something's got to happen something
someone's got to come forward and just
they can't keep everyone locked down and
keep their lips I want to see pictures
photographs you know video you know
again I don't know how close these guys
are really get to there again you know
the scary part is that the brilliant the
Brazilian authorities will kill you
that's what I was telling you about how
they don't play around there are no
civil rights there if they tell you stay
out of here or I'm gonna shoot you
better stay either you're gonna shot
soul eat that video or whatever it is
that so you know you take him you're
taking into consideration your life
literally if this is a true event and
you're going to go I'm gonna go get the
truth
be careful yeah be careful because it's
the I just knowed like I say those guys
did not play around from the perspective
I've seen them yeah and there's not
gonna be any warning shots they're
important shots are like yo
[Laughter]